[Music]
i'm glad you're here today because maybe
you can shed light on how this is even
possible a california woman who is
currently serving life in prison
cooperated with another prison employee
and together
they pulled a fraud scheme that scammed
two million in unemployment benefits wow
i don't know if i should say good for
them or should i say
i don't plan on the prisons that's kind
of cool well what they did was they
they used the names of other prisoners
and other people everywhere i heard
people doing that and just collected
tons of unemployment oh
interesting it's kind of like how they
get the dead people yeah and then they
sign them up
the guard or the other employee for the
prison was taking the records of the
files and and giving that to the
prisoner and together they were pulling
that whole thing wow there were some
dudes doing that when i was at uh
hurlong there was a guy there doing uh
uh income tax returns for dunes and
basically he was in their ball and him
and another guy were getting guys
informations and having the people on
the street and then follow the final
income tax and getting money and then he
would get a cut by showing the people
families and so they were getting money
sent on their books and they were
balling they made six figures people
filed for their taxes in jail well they
but he knew how to do it this dude he
was a columbian he was bawling he knew
like and he had another white guy who
was pretty smart and together they were
putting together like these frauds where
they were somehow doing returns or
something else to get money back
and
in exchange these people would have to
get give them a cut and so they had a
little network and they were doing it
somehow the prison found out and they
got busted but they were in there
running the coal racket similar to that
so you got some smart dudes in there who
know
you know how to go about like getting
money and making sure like that happened
so this stuff is pretty common yeah yeah
yeah in any way shape or form any way
shape or form if a guy knows how to
facilitate paperwork you know
the fraud game is you know that's one of
the easiest game but it's a paper trail
so eventually it's going to catch up to
you you know i'm still waiting to meet
that nigerian prince i sent money to but
he is too i don't know never give up
like covet you know yeah
yeah i'm sure i'm sure pretty uh out of
all the crimes you can do from prison
fraud is like one of the easier more
common ones you can pull off
yeah because
if you have access or somebody who knows
how to do certain things and then you
can utilize like say somebody's sitting
in there and they get like they apply
for an mx you know and they got some on
the street to get them thing somehow
sign up you know what i mean you can
work certainly they don't ever see that
person yeah so how do they know so if a
person's smart enough and they can
somehow build profiles up they can
create these profiles they got to buy
honest and like you said a guard who's
facilitating other stuff goes to a po
box they get it they blah blah blah
charge make moves you can make moves and
because people are just sitting dormant
so how's it ever going to collect
because it never really hits nowhere and
if a person keeps up floating they can
have a whole racket up in there it's
just how much time do you want to put
into
orchestrating that type of racket
knowing that it could possibly collapse
yeah you know which it eventually does
because somebody's going to tell or
they're going to get word of it but yeah
there's a lot of guys i would imagine
that have done that that haven't got
caught if they stopped in time
but yeah
just get too greedy get too greedy or
you you carry on the huffle like that
for too long in a paper trail somehow it
only takes one mistake and it it leads
back to whoever set up that initial
scheme because these guys i think when
they were doing attack they haven't been
doing that for some years
so he's doing 20 30 years he's like what
i got to lose is it pretty common that a
lot of like people who are still doing
crime in jail like how do they keep
getting these like guards to work with
them yeah well
you gotta look at a guard it's
fascinating with the fact that this guy
was able to make this kind of money and
a guard
at the same time you're dealing with a
guy who in prison who is very articulate
or well versed in and like let's just
say economics you know you got a guy
maybe who is running
maybe a real estate company or had an
llc that had knew how to build
credit line through dun and brad you
know so he knew how to build on that and
you tell a guard and the guard's sitting
there be like damn i wouldn't mind being
a millionaire or how to you know get
this of that going and make a little
extra money you know buy a nice car make
an extra 10 20 grand a month and if it's
not requiring you hurt nobody they think
that hey why not why not go ahead and
and do this and if they can trust a
person if a guy's a solid dude then they
feel like hey that's really it's worth
the risk you know it's like with
anything else of a person who's never
done crime and they get intrigued by
somebody who's made a success to a
degree
through crime even though they're locked
up
they would want to know like how do you
go about doing that how can i do you
know how much guards make
because like if they're making like 50
grand a year or something
and this guy's like yo how would you
like to make 10 grand a month yeah
they're probably going to be i don't
know it varies state to state yeah like
some states like guards could be 18
some states uh they're like post
certified so they're like actual cops so
it all depends it's not too much in
california for ceos the average is 42
000 a year and so they gotta get
overtime and like say if you're a guard
in certain prisons like the fed when
they outline when they outlawed
cigarettes like dude they're bringing in
like what are the canopy room costs
16 bucks you know that and print that
three hundred dollars
so if they sell cigarettes to the
prisoners do they get in trouble
probably a little bit right but not full
it's not dope yeah so how does money
transfer in in prison like does p
prisoners just have cash you you have
people send money to the streets on your
books you know i do legal work for
people i never have money sent in i'd
have them you know and make sure when
they send it to this person did it hit
okay cool okay i'll oh so it's not like
actual no no you don't even have to ever
see it it's just a matter of making sure
it's just like when guys there's poker
there's poker tables in prison prison
pockets they're making like there's
poker tables that are doing probably
some of them
50 grand a month
the buy is five grand in prison in
prison my boy's running a poker table
they're buying five grand you got and
you got maybe six people playing so each
person until they can't get into the
poker game until this five grand hits
and you can play up to that five grand
now when you get below i'll let you know
when you're down your last 500 bucks but
then if you win i'll also once you get
to a certain point i'll do payouts so
i'll do a payout do accounting you got
dudes like you're watching i'm you know
doing this you're keeping track you've
got books all this stuff and then a
guard let's you know hey this is the
black this is the asian table it's a
cell phone table and he kind of looks
out and you might you know um you know
hey man when you add this i'll shoot you
something all right you shoot him a
couple grand you know what i mean
because you're going to run your table
and it keeps people from violence
because you're gambling so you got guys
they guess all they do they'll leave the
cards and they'll go and [ __ ] and lock
down and come back to cars and be right
here to finish the game like seriously
yeah wow yeah yeah ultimate dealers huh
you know you're like these are the ball
like you might be
colombian dude oh that's like dude from
uh you know vietnamese dude this dude
right here he's um you know he's he's a
dope dealer from the bay that's doing
they're all playing doing this like the
table might be like 10 grand on table
you know what i mean they're playing
seriously actual money on the table or
they keep or they just keep the books
keep the books and they get to keep the
books they know but like you you know
because everybody's solid and the thing
is you don't want to go in a dead think
you're going to hide because you go to
the hole you go to another prison i'll
send word that you over here because
gamble's never going to stop gambling
yeah he'll go another prison go get
another table and it's gonna have you
know what i mean so it happened and so
before you can even get on the table you
cannot play until the money hits the
streets wow so you can't you know okay
now you cause there's a banker or
someone or who comes buddy on the
streets like oh you call oh yeah um blue
blue he's good oh hey okay tell me yeah
a little pit you know he's getting big
huh oh you know so you know what's up so
it's good for that dude you could come
play you're good so now you can and then
you keep track of what you're winning so
you know what you're so they get wire
instructions like they're they're like
everyone has someone that outside that's
their bank yeah you got to have like a
you know person that handle your maybe
you have your cousin your aunt your girl
yeah and you send money yeah handle
business you got to make sure like hey
man you don't ever want to get in the
hole and you know most people tell you
like you know you don't want to you
don't let somebody get in the hole to
begin with so that's why you tell them
that before they can play
and then you know once you get to that
level then you know a lot of people like
or they'll say hey man i'm i'm good and
you go they'll go to like another
machine look at my books oh damn you got
a hundred thousand on your book your
okay yeah you know because i know your
your your books say the account thing
said that your machine says you have
that much money on your books what's uh
when people say the books that's the
that's their jail bank right yes yes yes
that's the jail federal reserve
[Laughter]
other people can see it when they show
up your account they can well if i have
you come with me you know there's ways i
could like hey look you know i'm saying
so you're like oh okay but like
typically before anybody gives you any
credit you're going to have proof of
funds you know you're not going to show
up and the thing is you don't want to go
in there and think that you're going to
scam these dudes because do this they
got hitters there you know what i mean
it's like you don't want to deal with
that you don't want to get gunned down
by them no and then if you like
depending on the level of table you
might have um you might have um
before you do anything you might have to
go to give information in case you know
what i mean
so you don't want that to happen how do
you regulate when you're getting screwed
and you don't have a crew you don't have
anybody you can't get involved in that
you don't even mess with you that's what
i'm saying before you even tap into that
but i like poker
if you if you before you even tap into
that world you better already have
some type of uh
way of dealing with paying somebody and
somebody on the street that can
facilitate unless you if you have to
move funds around so you better you know
be sitting on some some hundreds of
thousands or millions on the streets
where you can make moves and you don't
mind losing you know twenty thirty
thousand a month is there a table that's
like this is like for the peewees these
are the this is the practice table oh
yeah they got guys like the stamford
like you know a hundred dollars couple
hundred bucks you know there's small
tables those tables those dudes get beat
up a lot more because they don't go try
chicks you know the poor table you know
they try and [ __ ] dudes like go to the
hole i'ma check in he owes like 300
bucks go to the hole somebody else goes
to the hole and they basically follow
you to the hole but you know typically
the holes like segregate segregation
like uh seg unit where you go and you're
like locked down and you just come out
for showers and stuff you think that
you're not gonna work you're not gonna
be on main line so you're off a main
line but there's people in mainline they
could they've got they have ways to send
messages
you know to get to like oh he's in the
hole because he checked in or he owes
and blah blah blah blah and then
eventually if they transfer to another
prison
i can send word through another way oh
he's got someone for institution and i
have i'll say hey man go ahead and check
out that debt for me he owes me this you
can have that though just send me back
whatever off of that so it always
follows are they trying to hide from
debt oh like getting incarcerated away
from everybody else yeah people man
people have been killed for you know
twenty dollar joint in there
dude they'll have no right because it's
it's principle yeah you know i mean so
you don't ever want to ruin the
principle that's different on the street
like oh man it's only there's only a
cigarette or whatever man it's principle
in there man and people take that
they're more honorable in their home
yeah yeah very that's why it's like
you're never gonna people aren't gonna
bump into you step on your shoes and say
excuse it's a different level of respect
so people on the street there's no
respect
because there's no consequence and there
you bump into somebody dude it's like
literally he'll kill you yeah he might
catch you the next day in the morning
and then you just mean you're you know
eating your little your little cereals
and dude come and start just jabbing you
because you disrespected him two weeks
ago he just he just plotted yeah they
plotted
he says chivalry's dead
not in jail
[Music]
you